don't be afraid to put yourself in
adverse situations because that's where
you're going to grow as a human being
the decisions you make in times of
adversity self-inflicted or or totally
out of your control are the things that
those decisions Define who you are as a
human but don't fear inflicting that
adversity on yourself because it's going
to help you grow as a human being go put
yourself through a little adversity it
may be only running for five minutes to
start with it may not be running it may
be something completely different than
that but don't fear it because I feel
like it's essential for us as as humans
to experience that in life adversity is
a tool man that's all it is